es gibt ja bei Länder wo es noch
schlimmer ist und das ist der Übergang
gut aber es sind ja heute hier um
eigentlich vor Erdogan zu warnen dass
die Stichwahl nicht zu seinen Gunsten
entschieden wird richtig also
ich bin heute ich muss hoffen weil ich
wieder irgendwann wieder einreisen und
ich will auch dass gerade meine Mutter
besuchen können und wenn er dann die
absolute Mehrheit hat ist es nicht die
Mehrheit sondern es Beweis nur wie viel
dunkel wird Türkei haben in diesem
Moment dann 49,3 %. weil wenn da wenn
die Wirtschaft so am Boden ist das 1 €
21 Liter sind die Menschen keine Arbeit
haben und die für Brot lange stehen
müssen aber immer nur wenn sogar
sieben Wochen gesagt haben wegen dir
sind wir tot keine Hilfe es gibt und der
Stadt war nicht da die haben will was
was will ich den Menschen sagen die kann
man nicht helfen also du kannst mit
einem dummen Menschen nicht diskutieren
und deine Ziele erwarten weil der Dumme
der denkt er ist dass der andere dümmer
ist und hält sich intelligent dass er
das Problem und wir müssen die kleine
Embryos die neu erzogen werden muss man
muss mit
Gefühlen haben und aber leider ist auch
Deutschland ein bisschen selber schuld
daran und die deutsche Politik auch die
europäische Politik war schauen Sie
Amerika wenn alle nicht darüber oder ein
Ländern wo es Wirtschaft aber in Europa
wie Holland Belgien in Deutschland wir
alle Erdogan weil wir in Europa nie
akzeptiert worden sind nein meiner
Meinung hat einen anderen Grund wo ist
denn die Vorgänger gemacht worden
ein Mensch wird nie also können nicht
wissen was bedeutet ein Türke sein denn
in Deutschland liegt natürlich nicht und
es gibt Rassismus ein Nein Lehrer zu mir
gesagt
und keinen in der Klasse hat es
bestätigt und dann hat sich alle
deutschen so geht es halt weiter und
wenn du mit diesem Hass groß wirst und
wir wollten ja von den Türken da unten
akzeptiert werden also das haben sie
nicht wir haben uns gehasst später
erfahren und dann haben sie deutschen
hier gehabt was sie auch in Ordnung war
aber da stand mir mittendrin ohne nichts
und dann kommt sagt ich Akzept für euch
und haben sich endlich die Türken
gefühlt deswegen sehen sie noch
ja aber ich glaube das ist zu kurz
Begriffen also wenn wenn ich mir Belege
wenn ich mir überlege wo ist die wo ist
die AKP Werbung wo wird die gemacht die
wird ja in Deutschland gemacht hätte
Deutschland alles richtig weil
Deutschland muss ich alles erlauben das
ist in Deutschland sein Problem hier in
meinem Freitag der darf seine
hasspredigen gehalten weil ihr alles
erlaubt wird Deutschland lässt sich
einfach alles erlauben gegen
Meinungsfreiheit in der Sendung konnte
dann kann ich dann ziehe ich vielleicht
zehn junge Kinder deutsche Kinder haben
meine Zeitung bringen den Islam so weit
dass wir Köpfen soll weißt du alles so
sagt und das darf ich sagen nur weil
Meinungsfreiheit gibt also irgendwo muss
irgendwo muss manchmal Schluss sein wie
lange musst du per Vogel in der Stadt
rumlaufen seine Brille halten
warum darf er sowas und Deutschland wird
deswegen wird der Integration nie
funktioniert weil die Politik braucht ja
Probleme dass sie auch eine gute
Ablehnung
wie Menschen auf sie reagieren wie
Türken auf sie reagieren wegen ihrer
Kritik
du bist ein Heuchler du bist ein Spinner
beleidigt mich wieder natürlich
zu werden du Idiot
funktioniert
das sind Erdogan Anhänger in Deutschland
sie gehen in den Diskurs weil sie die
auch überzeugen wollen dass es wichtig
aber wie ist es für Sie also ich finde
es ja furchtbar zu Wahl gegangen ich
wusste nicht ob ich zum Krieg irgendwie
gezogen bin da kommen sie sofort du
Bastard damit mit allen Wegen versuch
mich zu provozieren ich habe zum
70-jährigen Mann gesagt mir ist
scheißegal wie alt bist du noch einmal
Bastard ich dich und dann haben sie
schon die Polizei gesehen haben sich
gruppiert
arbeiten wenn die Kamera sehen Sie wie
immer ein bisschen ruhiger halten sich
auch zurück ich finde es einfach nur
schade das müsste da muss Deutschland
auch durchgreifen wieso dürfen wir
wählen wenn wir Türkei so wichtig ist
dann verpiss Dich ne je nach Türkei und
lebe dort aber es hat ein Grund wieso
besser geht wir haben alle dank
Deutschland für Deutsche Mark jetzt Euro
zwei drei Häuser Türkei das heißt sie
sind dagegen dass sie zum Beispiel in
der Türkei würden eine Frage wenn es so
und dein Gesetz entworfen wird betrifft
das
in Deutschland also warum soll ich damit
entscheiden ich die ruinieren das Leben
von Menschen und die Erdogan gar nicht
mehr wollen dann den Stimmen in Europa
im Ausland hat er gewonnen da haben sie
recht also dass die die
Wahlberechtigten in Deutschland sind das
ziemlich gut wenn ich auf der Straße
rumlaufe Türkei ist besser als
Deutschland
funktioniert wenn man das einmal
gecheckt hat dann funktioniert einfach
frei ich glaube sein kann
deutsch Türken und Menschen mit
türkischen Hintergrund auch hier gerne
arbeiten
kannst du mit mir natürlich schon die
Frage stellen wie es sein dann auch im
Verhältnis von Deutschland Türkei
gesehen dass mehr Deutsche Türken in
Deutschland Erdogan wählen als in der
Türkei und da muss und da muss man die
Frage stellen inwiefern diese Menschen
also wie kann man Erdogan wählen ein
Autokraten der auch in Islamisten
Unterstützer ist und selbst
fundamentalistische Religiosität
vertritt und auch das ganze Land
politisiert islamisch da muss man sich
wirklich fragen inwiefern die auch mit
unseren Grundwerten übereinstimmen und
ob die Integration bei denen auch
gescheitert werden ob die Integration
bei denen einfach versagt hat einfach
gesagt ich hatte nur das Glück nicht
menschlich etwas entwickeln konnte
aber ich habe mir ein Menschen
entwickelt andere Kulturen gesehen habe
weil der der Tür gearbeitet hier 11
Monate bereits vier Wochen dann die
Türkei zeigt einen tollen Mercedes
erklärt vielleicht teilweise Toilette
putzen muss und dann poliert
und der Türke aber wir können jetzt
draußen sind
sagen ein deutscher zu mir gesagt dass
deine Heimat du bist zu Hause wir wurden
alle diskriminiert und das ist heute nur
so wir können in Schule gehen die Kinder
werden nur von Lehrern scheiße sind zu
Hause in Deutschland in der Türkei
ich weiß nicht wie es da unten ist als
ob du noch nie geliebt willst du kannst
nicht sagen aber hier mir geht's gut ja
ich liebe Deutschland wird es genauso
beschützen in Deutschland also die
Türkei weil ich habe alles in diesem
Land zu verdanken deswegen nehmen
der genau das ist das was wir sind hier
geboren
das ist doch Rassismus das muss nicht
zugeben ich muss zugeben ich finde sie
sollten entscheiden dürfen
Integration in diesem Land auf sich ja
gut also diese 1,6 Millionen türkischen
Wähler die da mehr hätte ich für Erdogan
gestimmt haben die sind durch die Beweis
dafür dass es eine Parallelgesellschaft
gibt in der die demokratischen Werte
unseres Landes nicht akzeptiert werden
aber wenn es wenn sie recht haben und
die Mehrheit der Türken sind tatsächlich
so dumm gewählt zu haben
dann wieder viele mit deutschen
Staatsangehörigkeit hätte gar nicht
wahlberechtigt sind
dann gibt es aber auch die dummen in
Anatolien ja dann gibt es doch keine
Hoffnung auf die Stichwahl also die
Großstädte haben alle die Operation
gewählt und die kleinen Dörfer haben
natürlich erdogge gewesen
eine Hoffnung dass die Leute anders sind
wirklich anders abstimmen die Türken
sind sie für Deutschland entschieden
jetzt ja plötzlich Türke
die Türken sind schnell umzulegen also
man muss ein bisschen den nationalso
wecken und schon sind wir anders das
macht immer er macht immer Nationalisten
Türkei hast du Fußballschuhe bist ein
Fußball
aber wirklich sehr einfach heute hier am
Tisch die Welt also sie versuchen immer
immer irgendetwas nie gesagt habe ich
will nur sagen ich finde sie sehr
spannend als Charakter glauben Sie mir
das sonst würde ich sie gar nicht so
lange ausreden lassen
permanent was kann man denn tun weil man
merkt ihr ganz klar Handlungsbedarf also
ein Vorschlag war ja schon dass Menschen
die in Deutschland leben nicht in der
Türkei wählen dürfen das wäre ein ganz
klarer Vorschlag ich glaube das lässt
sich nicht realisieren weil auch
deutsche mit doppelstaatsangehörigkeit
die im Ausland leben können auch
theoretisch in Deutschland wählen also
das sind internationale Geflogenheiten
die können wir die brauchen wir glaube
ich jetzt hier nicht zu diskutieren aber
wir könnten viele andere Versäumnisse
der Integration muss man ganz einfach
sagen ja anfänglich ist es ja die
Gastarbeiter gehen alle wieder zurück
auch die Leute selber dachten ja und
dann da hat man
anfänglich überhaupt nicht drauf
geachtet dass das ist hier vielleicht
ein integrieren geben sollte dann sind
die Leute geblieben und man hat trotzdem
wieder Fehler gemacht man hat
beispielsweise die religiösen
Institutionen der Türkei überlassen die
die beispielsweise hat hier die
religiöse Betreuung übernommen die
milliarisch hat man hier ähm Moscheen
bauen lassen und andere Organisation
und äh hat jetzt die die die die war ja
ursprünglich meine eher säkulare ähm
islamische Organisation unter Kontrolle
des Staates und der erdogan ist sie dann
eher eine islamistische Richtung
gewandert
aber ich finde
dass der deutsche Staat immer noch ein
Fehler macht immer noch den Fehler macht
Migranten aus muslimischen Ländern
vornehmlich als Muslime zu sehen ja und
auch mit der Islam-Konferenz ein
spezielle Konferenz nur für Muslime das
hat Dir völlig falschen Zeichen gesetzt
und jetzt ähm lassen sich Politiker beim
Iftar in Moscheen abpflichten weil sie
denken das kommt irgendwie gut
meine neue Sendung eröffnen weil wir
sind leider schon am Ende genau
noch mal eins und lässt aber auch zu das
Moscheen als Orte für Wahlkampf
missbraucht werden das kann man nicht
machen vielleicht sollte man eher ähm
statt Staatsbürger für
bürgerschaftsoffensident er eine
offensive mal machen sich zu bekennen
auch zu diesem Land als Deutscher egal
wo man herkommt und mal eine große
Kampagne wir lieben Deutschland zu
machen und und das sozusagen als
inklusionsangebot für alle die hier
gerne leben wollen die hier mit den
Werten einverstanden sind und hier etwas
zu beitragen wollen ich glaube das ist
in einer pluralistischen Gesellschaft
notwendig und ich würde sagen wir müssen
auf jeden Fall noch mal über die Türkei
Erdogan und Integration hier debattieren
das war jetzt etwas kurz am Ende ich
wünsche dir noch einen schönen Abend
morgen abends wir wieder für Sie da
machen sie es gut bis morgen wurden sie
abgezockt oder reingelegt
das ist also eine Verzehnfachung jetzt
melden unsere Reporter kümmern sich um
Ihren Fall
kämpft für Sie